foreign
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is Dane Cook Dane Cook
is a comedian and like a revitalized
comedian I mean I remember him from way
back in the day and he's he's like he's
coming back around again he has a new
show called above it all um he's also
touring filming a documentary right now
this is a conversation that didn't go in
all the ways that you think it would go
in like super fun and interesting ways
yes it was funny and yes he's very
interesting but he's so deep like he's a
lot like me like our mission for truth
being introverts and loving to be home
but like also like when we're out we're
out and being able to entertain and be
on stage and the way that we both want
to just go deep into ourselves to figure
life out and and make the most of it and
be happy there was just tons of life
lessons and his sharing about his
childhood and what has sort of like made
him the person that he is and how he
feels on stage and what makes good
comedy I set a little intention this
morning that I wanted to laugh a lot and
I wanted to have delight and surprise
today and that was my delight and
surprise Dane Cook was a delight and
surprise so I hope you enjoy it nearly
as much as I did please hit the
Subscribe button and the bell for
notifications and in the comments
I'm curious what you think about this
one today's pretty intense partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
greens literally every day I gave ag1 a
try because I wanted to nourish my gut
health I wanted to have more energy I
wanted to add more micronutrients to my
body I take it first thing in the
morning before I have coffee and then
before I go work out it makes me feel so
good I'm giving my body the nutrition it
craves if a comprehensive solution is
what you need from your supplement
routine then try ag1 and get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and get
five free ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase go to drinkag1.com pretty
intense that's
drinkag1.com pretty intense check it out
fun for 32 years isn't that what you
said always fun for 32 years is that it
feels it still feels like the first year
I'm 51 I started stand up out of Boston
32 years ago this month
well I kind of knew you weren't 32 but I
didn't know exactly how old you were I
mean I remember using I'm not 32. I'm 41
now so well look at us looking all great
and Sassy it's probably the exposure on
my camera mostly but yeah a fun
um why why do you think you've been able
to have fun for 32 years
oh diving right in with uh okay that's a
scorcher and I'll tell you because I
spend so much time
um I I love reading and I'm a big
proponent of the inward Journey as much
as the the road outward in stand-up has
been uh tremendous and tumultuous and
exciting and dare I say effervescent
um that Journey inward has always been
equally as
um
uh fascinating for me you know what
makes us tick you know why do we do what
we do decisions we make you know how do
we overcome capsizing moments traumatic
moments so I think what keeps me vibrant
and excited is that I'm I'm in a
Perpetual state of recalibration and I
like that I like re rebuilding the
engine coming and that's a new act over
here year to year and then it's uh
Tools in Your Arsenal on how to be
you know more compassionate more
empathetic uh just a better version of
yourself so it's kind of a constant uh
you know state of uh forward progression
in in personal and professional how many
therapists do you have simultaneously
and one I got one good one I actually
got one right out of the gate it was
kind of interesting well my parents had
passed away I lost both my mom and dad
to cancer in the same year not as funny
as what I just laughed for sure no no
it's okay I I we dovetailed from the
laugh so uh that won't that won't uh you
know that doesn't blemish either of us
to to and by the way I had a very funny
family and and there is a lot of
laughter even in the most
um upsetting moments we would we would
find our way uh through with laughter
but for me I didn't grieve for a few
years because I was so busy that I
thought oh I'm just good I'm working I'm
active I'm doing what my parents raised
me to do I'm happy and then when it
finally started to you know I don't know
like to put it simply catch up to me
yeah uh I was like you know what I think
I'm gonna you know sit with somebody and
see if I can start uh trying to you know
figure out how I'm wired with this and
that was exceptional I I got lucky I got
right out of the gate Great therapist it
only took us about a year and a half for
me to be very honest
that's not bad actually you know you sit
down you think why should I tell you
stranger everything about me like you
know it's it's it's hard to be able to
just let go and go to that space so I
actually think a year and a half for
being really honest is not too bad kind
of I get like fixated on getting to the
truth of whatever it is that I eat if
it's a script if it's a you know Comedy
Tour if it's even just you know in my
office and in writing I'm always trying
to get to like the real nitty-gritty of
like what am I about what is this really
about why am I doing it stop it we're
like so much more similar than I was
expecting okay good like your journey
that's my life
um is like the whys the hows the what's
the nature of reality the nature of me
like what's my patterns what's my part
how are you on your journey if you were
kind of moving the needle are are you oh
are you in the green are you in the red
are you where are you at yeah I'm in the
green right now and I would say that
like just um we won't talk about me much
but getting to the point where like you
get past the initial phase of feeling
like it's all really hard and you're
like wait this Journeys feels worse most
of the time than it feels good like the
ratio's off
once you get past the initial hump then
it's actually like a better Baseline all
the time and getting to the point now
where I am asking myself the question
what's my part in this every time no
matter what and then being able to see
things from an observer perspective like
even when someone does like I'll be
walking my dogs and they'll be off leash
and somebody like put your dog on a
leash and the old me would have been
like [__] you [__] you if I put the
zapper collar on your neck you'd listen
too you know like now I'm like I just
see it like this person would never let
their dog off a leash so they just are
triggered you know this isn't it's not
my stuff it's their stuff
um so the Observer perspective feels
really good and how quickly you're able
to
um the mechanics uh what do they call it
in working out like the impact rep that
impact rep how do I respond here and how
quickly you can realize I'm not gonna go
there the the old way of doing it and
here's the healthier better hopefully
more outstanding version myself showing
up here to help me through what was your
what was your Arc like well well so the
first part of my life I was an introvert
I was self-loathing I had a lot of fear
I came from a phobic mother I came from
an alcoholic father who was very very
brilliant decent guy until uh the
drinking
so I described the first part of my life
is not only was I
um off kilter but I not not realizing
from an alcoholic home that I lived on a
tilt you know you live skewed and
constantly not sure how to balance
um so all of those things when I finally
hit stand up and found purpose and this
thing that I I loved the first part of
my life it was never about me and I was
like why can't anything be about me I'm
scared I'm nobody wants to include me I
feel lost I feel I'm an introvert and
then years later it's like it all became
about me
and so I was building all those voids
from who I came from and not really
realizing that was all just kind of uh
Superfluous of course I'm fast tracking
and I'm skipping a lot but I think at
the heart of your question it's like I I
didn't know how to be present for a long
time in my life I was either running
from the kid that I didn't like of
myself or I was running to the next
um Mountain that I was I was succeeding
if I have another Mountain then I don't
need to look back right I'm I'm in it to
win it so it took me a minute to finally
understand like what real Zen was in
balance and the truth which is also you
saying that like I
I've said many times that but that this
life is about me just figuring out the
truth of everything like what's the
nature of this reality what's the nature
of me what am I really here for what's
how am I best serving yeah how am I how
am I broken and how is how is that okay
and then what does that mean for how
like I uh intercept other people's pain
and then how do I give people my power
and share truly what I'm all about
have you figured that part out
you know
I I I understand it I have a better you
know I
I am a flawed person I have a lot to
share and a lot of ability and things
that I have discovered that I love about
life and about myself but I also know in
it I can at least identify the places
that I didn't have boundaries and where
for a long time I let people just Pummel
me dude I mean like I didn't even know
boundaries really meant no everybody was
invited for a while it was like You Like
Me Now oh everybody there was no mindful
thoughtful compassionate collaborative
caring as I talk about now in my
stand-up and I have kind of jokes about
my therapy sneaks into my act because I
always want to find the laugh but
there's so many things that have
enriched my life that ends up as fodder
for the stand up but those five things
that you know mindfulness did not yeah
that came late to the party for me like
mindfulness of yourself mindfulness of
your
surroundings like go more into that one
yeah looking at the relationships that I
had and having to do diligence and take
the take the time and look for the
necessary traits and emotional you know
values that that a good person maybe at
a great place in their their life is
going to be able to hang with you and it
isn't about drama and it's not about
taking anything away from anybody who
are the people that kind of like are
also in that Zen comfortable place or at
least in the place of like doing the
work and realizing I too have my you
know flaws and issues and those people I
can hang with all day if you bring me
the worst truth I I love you
if you if you put on a game face and a
facade and it's still awesome I don't I
don't want to be around that I don't
care how great it feels to be around a a
faux version of you I want the ugly
truth of somebody so that I can feel
like well I can tell you some things
about me that like I'm still in a work
in progress on do you feel like that you
um gave a lot of time and energy to
people that were manipulative or brought
you down it is Hollywood so yes uh you
kind of sign up for I wish there was
like a real you know definitive mission
statement of like show up here and get
ready because it's you know all the the
ten thousand hours and the things that
you hear you know from great seminars or
I used to go to AAA meetings with my
friends after gigs because I I've never
drank I've never had a drink in my life
but I loved going to support friends but
I learned so much and I again I liked I
liked that there was a a proof even
though it was Stark and really hard
sometimes to be in those rooms I found
myself really it was alluring because I
was like I want to be this real I want
to admit some of these things about
myself that like that are you know kind
of like boiling inside of me that I'm
unsure about so I think that when I got
to this this industry
and then I made it it was like the
undertow for a while I I really didn't
know what end was up because the
community when you're the bell of the
ball has a real way of making it feel
like you're important forever
you know yeah so you come back down to
earth and then you start to go like okay
we're you know what is real life here
what am I truly what what brings me
happiness day to day and not the big
mountain that I think I'm gonna always
jump over because you're just constantly
jumping from dopamine hit to dopamine
hit
and I think because I do I'm one of
those people I subscribe a lot to like
the the child inside and how we're you
know formulated from so many of our
early surroundings and I had a I had a
mom opposite to my dad who was
unfortunately self-defeating and then
would drink my Maham would quite
literally say things like um knowing I
was insecure right knowing that I'm
that I'm having trouble like social
anxiety she would say things like uh
every night when you know I'd be going
to bed she'd come in and say good night
and I'd say mom what if I want to be a
baker and she would say you will be the
best baker in the world your bakery will
be renowned you will have people
visiting from around the world the next
night Mom what if I wanted to be like
have heists what if I wanted she'd say
you would be the best big robber you
would come up and she she wanted to
build me up because I was so the
opposite that when I said I'm going to
be a stand-up comedian I was 15 and she
said I knew from when you were very
little
that you're going to do something really
special and that you are going to make
people happy even though you feel
unhappy a lot you'll understand how
important it is to have that happiness
in your life and it was true I loved
comedy I love when my family was funny
because it kept us away from the the
dark stuff but for me
my communication my My love language was
humor that was it and so she made me
believe that yeah there's a mountain of
course any mountain you could always
that's yours take it it took me a long
time to realize that's also the
messaging it was like I love my mom was
my compass I would not be here without
her the most incredible energy that I
could have ever asked for in my life was
my mom and yet
I think her own fears phobias things
that she missed out on and then seeing
me and realizing I just don't want him
to have that thing that I have I want
him to shoot for the moon you know she
she didn't because she didn't shoot for
the moon or she was just trying to fill
in the gaps for you like a good mom to
be able to yeah I think I think Danica
with my mom it was it was fascinating
because I was watching Oprah one time I
was like a mama's boy I come home from
school we watch Oprah and I remember my
mom what time the uh the Radio City
Rockettes were on
and they're all kick in and do you know
beautiful outfits and the the whole you
know shebang and my mom started to cry
my mom by the way was a love dancing and
my mom had beautiful legs like long the
longest Gams as she would say yeah and
she was weeping
I said Mom what's what's the matter and
she said I feel like I could have done
something beautiful like this I wish
that I had done something like this I
feel like when I see people like these
people I'm drawn to that and I'm I feel
like I missed out
and it was interesting because not only
in that moment was I like well you're an
incredible mother and I'm trying to talk
her up as a son the best I can at 13 or
14. but I was watching Saturday Night
Live those same Saturday nights watching
uh Martin Short on there doing skits and
killing and saying I want to be there I
want to stand with those people I don't
know who those people are they feel like
they'd like me they feel like they would
accept me and I had the same thing as my
mom but I wasn't going to not see it
through even if it didn't work I was
gonna go as far to my radio city as I
possibly could funny I was just talking
to a girlfriend today and
talking about the scenario of a podcast
that came out and sending it to someone
that it would be applicable for but
maybe they're a bit young for it at this
point in time and I was like hey hey
never underestimate the power of
planting a seed if they can't hear it if
they don't know what it means they just
won't hear it but it's still going in
so is it safe to say that if your mom
didn't say that about the Rockettes that
day that it would have had that there
would have been a different effort level
for comedy
I think there it was a culmination of
things but I very clearly I was in a
dark place as a kid and I was in
constant need of
um
some kind of building up that my mom
could very clearly provide
um so I think it was a it was a
combination of things but I but when I
did theater in high school and I was
brave enough to join the class at all
because I was terrified to even join
drama with 15 kids but standing on a
stage there feeling like oh man
something you know like teleports me I'm
I'm brave on stage but in life I'm very
fearful and then stand up uh Open Mic
nights right after I graduated high
school when I would take the mic in my
hand
it just that was the only place that I
felt really uh present and I felt like I
had something that I had to put my whole
heart into that meant something to just
me but also if I succeed in it make the
people laugh maybe it'll perpetuate me
forward and have purpose in life so it
was kind of like all it was all building
up to that first open mic night in
Boston that I finally realized man I I I
found some importance in myself to me
for me I mean that would be terrifying
for just about every single human being
in the world I mean it'd be terrifying
for me because I and I don't mind being
on a stage or talking or anything it's
like that doesn't bother me
but to have it be comedy like to find
someone that is willing to stand on
stage and someone that's willing to be
vulnerable enough to I mean it's an
immediate reaction either you let people
laugh or they don't they're equal they
are both a reaction and so I I'm like I
want to like um I want to excavate this
a little bit like how what is it that's
happening have you you I don't know if
you've gone into this or figured it out
but what is it when you get the mic and
get on stage is it
you know something's flowing through you
having sometimes with creatives they're
they're like the song or the book or
whatever comes through me I it's not me
it's something coming through me is it
something like that or is it like uh do
you enter like a different sort of like
mental Dimension where you're because I
think that with my racing when I raced I
was like I mean shoot I think you enter
a different frequency with your mind
that you know no matter what is going on
it gets eliminated and I always use the
stupid example of I was like hopped up
on DayQuil one morning uh before I drove
Martinsville and it was just a practice
day but I took the DayQuil before I ate
and I was like whoa I feel drunk and I
had to go around Martinsville which is
this half mile flat track where it's
just accelerating breaking accelerating
breaking and I was like holy [__] how am
I gonna do this and I was like super
fast and I was like oh and I never felt
it which made me realize that we don't
we're not in the same space out there
that we are in regular life so do you
feel like because I know for me and you
as a an athlete and I'm the son of an
athlete my dad went to BC boxing
basketball football super super
confident
um
you're a pressure player you're a
pressure performer probably in more
areas than just the racing where you
probably don't even realize what you're
capable of sometimes until it goes wrong
yeah yeah that's true that's true I I've
kind of even realized that with like my
best races were usually the ones where
there was the most pressure it's like
Indy 500 Daytona 500 like the ones that
were bigger were the ones that like you
know it was five years ago today
actually I just posted a story that um I
qualified in the top nine it's like this
fast nine and there's it's hard to do
and um I hadn't driven in Indy car in
seven years and I went back and like
qualified really well and so yeah you're
not you don't know what you're capable
of until you get in that position so
back to you like what is happening what
what do you feel up there or what don't
you feel well kind of
you know hitching it onto the pressure
player was I wasn't very good in school
um I wouldn't really do homework I
avoided I was terrible at many math and
certain things
um
when I tried to do homework in advance I
would get you know like C minus or
whatever but when I had one hour and
before the class was frantically trying
to learn what I needed to or I had to
kind of make it up on the Fly I was
great and I would be like wait how am I
getting A's and B's when I'm kind of
terrified putting myself in a hole
jump that into stand up
um I don't write a sent list down I at
first I used to try to write the sent
list you know you're and what I found
was that like oh man when I try to stick
to this I feel false but when I wing it
um I say things that I'm I don't even
know how I did that and and I'll find
language and vernacular out of nowhere
like you know words will come in and so
I start to realize oh wow I'm I'm uh I
am an athlete I am the son of my father
and I'm better when I'm not so
conditioned and formulaic that's the
thing I was better when I could kind of
improvise and what that helps in stand
up is then you're kind of reading the
room if you go into a room you I'm gonna
say these five funny things but you're
not thinking of like how's the night
been is the crowd a good crowd what's
happening in the world culture uh is the
manager screaming at somebody at the bar
and that's making people nervous in the
back is there a waitress and she's uh
you know dealing with somebody who could
potentially be like threatening or a
Heckler you have to be able to go into a
situation and go here's my routine but
I'm fluid
and that's scarier because you're not
leaning on anything you're just trusting
you're going to be okay the only thing I
could ever bring it to stand up that I
think people understand in sports is
it's kind of like being a pitcher in
baseball it doesn't matter how great
your last pitch was you're up there
alone
everybody's waiting for you to do
something great and doesn't the perfect
mechanics and the perfect pitch don't
matter that next pitch the crowd doesn't
nobody cares even though that was a
great pitch and it's like that in stand
up I Gotta Laugh doesn't matter I gotta
go to the next one it's got to be as
good 90 mile an hour straight down the
middle and being in that that headspace
on stage
I felt like the person I always wanted
to be cut to leaving the stage and that
kid's still waiting for me with all the
you know early in my career people be
like man you weren't very
um uh friendly you weren't really
ingratiating yourself in the community
outside of a few Comics that I really
knew and trusted I told people years
later I was scared
I looked so confident up there at the
helm with the guy in the you know oh
yeah yeah no I was like still trying to
figure out I I had no spot I was beta
I'm very Alpha now I became Alpha I was
very beta about that then I didn't have
the the um
the confidence to look you in the eye
and let you get to know me in a very
real way I did not know how to do that
for a for a longer time than what the
stand-up indicated at first but being up
there was like a superpower and that was
the person that I wanted to be I wanted
to be me on stage in life and try to
figure out how to like reverse engineer
it to become more um present off stage
sounds like you did
I did I did yeah it took a minute but
once I started getting into the that
then you know what's so weird Danica
then I started to realize man this
[__] up life and this how it's always
so challenging the pendulum does swing
both ways but it seems like it swings
into the hardship faster way harder
right for longer that thrust but I I
started to like I I got to a place some
years back 10 years back where I was
like I'm okay with failure I like it I'm
cool with it I wear it I [__] up
I I find data in that I get way more
I'll fail five times and I'll still you
can go man those five things sucked I'm
winning I'm I'm picking things up from
there I'm not repeating the failure I'm
not gonna continue to do something to be
derivative and abuse myself and failure
but I got to this place where I was like
man I'm I'm really okay with this life
sometimes kicking the [__] out of you
because that's what I think weirdly
we've all signed up for in a way I don't
know what's on the other end of it or
what the report card is after or the
simulation replay but it I I just
started to be okay with like it's okay
to not feel comfortable all the time
it's okay to feel lost it's okay to feel
um anti-climactic in your perceptions
and dreams It All Leads to what I think
is greater days and greater purpose
sometimes there's like an impetus for
that like and you know there's something
happen that made you go oh wow that
failure was actually the best damn thing
ever was there a situation that you're
that
gave you that sort of
um really strong stance to be able to be
okay with that failure because it seems
like a that's a giant lesson yeah I
think it was you know moments that
you're enlightened in realizing okay
wait how can I be so happy
in a moment of victory in a career but
then
um abuse myself in ways the way some
people will imbibe in drugs or alcohol
like I I was surrounding myself
especially in love earlier in my life
with people that were were
um you know not
kind with me not um and it was like
just people that that I felt like was
like man this is like um becoming
um
distracting almost to like the happiness
that I want to feel because of the the
purpose that I have and it took in that
enlightened moment of realizing oh I'm
I'm the son of an alcoholic and I know
the love of alcoholism and I also
realize in life we're magnets to like
want to have the same way we want to
have people identify the things that are
great about us if we have something
hidden in ourselves that's either needs
to be forgiven or wants the opposite or
something you know the toxicity feeling
polluted you you will bring people in
your life to pull that out of you as
well because that is your truth you will
be Victorious and you will feel
worthless and you'll find people to help
accentuate both it's not just one-sided
and wins make the
the the you know the the dark stuff go
away no you'll you'll be in
relationships where you're like man this
person is pulling out the couple of
things the minutia that I don't like
about myself and I I'm with that person
because I want them to reveal me to me
well we can't see ourselves that's the
damn conundrum of being that we can't
it's like a computer doesn't know it's a
computer right like it doesn't know the
programming it has no idea it's like iOS
3 or whatever I don't even know and so
you don't know what your programming is
and especially because so much of it
happens until we're about six seven
years old is when most of our
subconscious programming is established
which is about 95 of how we operate
so we see ourselves through other people
which is just crazy and like almost no
one knows and gets that right so how
where where did you stumble upon that
because I'm 41 and I just figured that
out like you know
a few years back I had a buddy about 10
or 11 years ago
um one of my best friends and he sat
down he said um
you uh
you seek love from alcoholics you you
seek the love of alcoholism and crazy I
don't drink never had a drink or drug in
my life and and and but it was an aha
moment because in it I was like
I understood almost immediately when he
you know just said it straight up he's
like and he brought up some examples and
he's like this person came into your
life suddenly they were athletic like
you and they want to go rock climbing
and this that and they don't drink at
all and then five months later they're
you know just day drinking and this and
that and he goes what would your dad do
I say my dad would drink and then for
three weeks it would be I'm sorry and
the best love ever until and then it
turned into that you know same Perpetual
state of like oh my goodness like what
how do we get through this as a family
and then he would sober up in four
months and it was and that's what I knew
and it was like I I hug him every time I
see him and I thank him almost like the
same day that he brought it to my
awareness that he loved me enough to go
that's who you're drawing in and so I
just you know started I don't know
sussing out the kind of people and what
their backstory was you got to learn
about people you know you gotta know
your origin you gotta in friendships and
anything in business gotta ask questions
get to know people get to know their
intentions see how mindful they are and
then from that I built uh a better
communication process for
falling in love or anything changed all
my friendships even some of my
friendship I recalibrated my whole life
based around that understanding of like
um I need healthier people around me are
you in a very very sensitive intuitive
person
um I'm a Pisces I guess that's kind of
part of it right it's like I'm on the
Aries cusp too so it's for the first
time I went through everyone I was
interviewing this week and I looked up
their birth dates not because I want to
be a uh what men would I usually call
like a crazy girl and always bringing up
astrology because I know something about
you because I know your sign and so you
have a shirt that says fight that
feeling you talked about never drinking
and doing drugs which usually the people
that don't do that I feel
um they are very sensitive and it's too
overwhelming or they're so sensitive
that they do a ton of it because they
need to numb out because they have so
much feeling and information coming in
so you can go both ways right yeah and
so I'm asking that because and you're
also very deep and Pisces is usually
very mental very deep very
um intuitive like you're one of the most
intuitive signs so
and then you talked about reading the
room so like I don't need any more signs
and anymore and any more information to
know that about you so I guess I'm
asking but I'm pretty sure I'm right oh
you're you are a hundred percent yes
very very sensitive very sensitive what
was that like that to be into I mean to
me that was probably your childhood and
why it was challenging and why you
probably spent a lot of time around
people that might not have been the best
for you because you didn't want them to
feel bad by saying I don't want to be
friends with you or not or not giving
them their attention the attention that
they wanted and so you hurt yourself in
the end to try and not hurt them because
you know how they feel and you care how
they feel so much true like feeling
empathy constantly because of knowing
how I felt to feel
um
you know cast aside or ignored or you
know all those things feeling like a
Wallflower and watching the world go by
but also realizing I'm a person that
like you know that saying um
you know people the walking wounded like
I want to help people even if I know
you're holding knives I still want to be
the person who believes like maybe I can
help you drop them and throw the hug
um so yeah definitely you know but not
something that you would ever want to
change even though I had to toughen up
and I had to learn to be a lot of things
um but no at the core I still do wake up
on those days and and just like that kid
who would say to my mom why don't people
like me if I'm having that time in my
life I'll still wake up sometimes be
like I wish that person would just get
to know me they might you know have a
different opinion so it's still that
same narrative sometimes yeah yeah it's
um
kind of like the ego right we don't
really we don't we don't actually we
don't want we don't want to get rid of
the ego we just need to make friends
with it we need to understand the
information that it's providing and so
your sensitivity is providing
information and it's not a matter of not
feeling because it's a superpower too
but man that's a that's a heavy that's
like a a very interesting
reality for you and then to be in comedy
I mean what's the positive and negative
of that because it's probably pretty
strong Duality there the positive way
outweighs everything else the positive
is
I've had um
I've had way too many moments to even
measure
that because of my popularity I've been
able to like do I just didn't make a
wish I met this amazing kid and to know
that your your comedy is helping
somebody through like the worst hardship
right something that you can't even
really qualify and you're you're hearing
somebody share their story a young
person especially it's like so on the on
the upshot when that when the spotlight
hits me and it may not have been like
this in my earlier ego you know years
but now it's like who can I bring in
here I want to shine that light on as
many people
um you know somebody on the come up in
comedy somebody who's trying to whatever
like uh Escape some kind of hardship you
know working with different you know uh
Charities and just doing anything you
can to go like all right lights on me
how can I include more people to
to hopefully get them to overcome an
early uh stumbling block moment in their
life the other side of it the heart the
hard side which is gonna sound so um
it compared to you know opening with
that it sounds kind of petty but like I
want to win I love winning I don't want
to beat you I don't care about beating
anybody it's always been a personal
competitive thing and I want to show
more of my ability
but only I know what it is and only I
know my true passion and after you hit a
moment especially in stand up where it
doesn't matter how white hot you are
when it starts to cool you still have
that same want and need to go oh let me
show you what else I can do or I've
learned something new and that might
always not always be zeitgeisting at the
moment so that's the opposite the great
side is you get to share the wins and
put wins in the win column and go like
ah now I can you know 32 years in I can
uh have an impact on somebody else's
life maybe with comedy or even who I am
off stage because of the success the
other side is sometimes you just want to
play in the sandbox still and go man I
wish I got a call on that I I wish that
somebody
um would hit me up and go hey do you
want to come participate in our thing
and I think in stand-up people always
think it's your thing you're doing it
alone over there and it makes it
difficult sometimes to get an invite
because nobody believes that you're
actually looking for somebody to reach
out a hand and go come over here and
hang with us which again goes right back
to Danica the kid I was you know that
wanted to feel included I still just
want to feel included even though I've
done everything to make my own thing
where you're invited and you're included
but I still want to be included you know
I interviewed Jillian torrecki
um before you and she's a psychologist
and one of the things she says is that
you know the the want to be loved and
um and chosen is
is fundamental in all of us
like this isn't we're not you know
that's not just your it's not just you
that's everybody everybody wants to be
included and Community is foundational
to our existence I mean I also
interviewed a guy named Matthias to
Stefano I don't know how deep into
woo-woo stuff you get but he's a guy who
um remembers all of his past lives and
but he basically said that I'm like
what's the what's the end game like
what's the point of this human existence
and where we're going and what's what's
where where what's our trajectory and
it's like well we're a virus we're a
virus and we're we're just the the the
goal is to be the the virus and that's
the head like the main virus in this
universe right
so like a virus can't do it alone like
we're meant to like I mean cancer has
also been shown to be
um a loss of cell communication so you
know there's fractal nature to all of
this these they're not separate they're
all we we feel like we're separate from
these things but it's all a kind of
common theme so it's so you have total
permission to want to be wanted that's
that's totally normal yeah I think it's
there's something in completion with I
had a teacher Lucille Bert who is my
creative writing and journalism teacher
in high school uh classes three and six
uh and I remember Lucille was would ask
the question what do you what do you
what are you going to do to be a
contributing member of your community
she had it on the Blackboard one day it
made such a strong impact she made a
very strong impact on me she was
probably one of the first people in my
life that really
um had me looking Beyond just you know
um
beer you know what I mean there was
possibility she was always inspiring
possibility
and that question it was like oh wow it
impacted me in the way this conversation
is impacting me because I think that is
still forever the the map that I'm
looking at is going like I know what I
love to do I know what I contribute I
know how I want to contribute to the
community around me I know how I've had
these things build me up in my own life
and I feel like I've got a great home I
have a home that I love to be I love
Stillness I love
I I don't have that tilted home I have a
you know very stable secure
home and yet looking at the map and
still saying but where do I belong now
that I have all this stuff to share
great conversation participation I've
had it all I've lost it all I've had
successes I've had absolute catastrophic
loss
where do I bring it and so
you know dovetailing from what you just
said it's like yeah what
having all this what do I do next where
is where is next away from a show with
the mic in the hand and getting the
laughs it really is like where am I
taking all this stuff now so what other
things make you feel seen and what are
your other Hobbies I think I saw that
you like video games a lot so I do
um I uh like what are the other things
that feed you that you are building up I
think you're also filming a documentary
is that correct too yeah and that's a
lot of work good for you
um the gaming is has always been like my
golf I I just love it I think it's like
meditation I I because I'm a ruminator
I'm constantly in the office love it but
not in the way that's um loud I just
love thinking I I just I want to look
something up all the time and understand
it better and you'll name somebody and I
want to go and research them and I have
an insatiable love of filling up my
brain me too yeah so nobody not in a way
that like I don't have to go like off
off it's never been like that it's just
um I feel alive when I'm thinking and
and listening even if I'm I enjoy
listening to somebody I don't even
like or respond to their opinion I'm
just as fascinated listening to somebody
passionate about what I think is their
wrong idea
this is information you're like but why
and could I change my mind yeah yeah or
what brought them to what is their
origin how did they get to that point
gaming is one of the couple of and and I
love I do racquetball I love activity
but gaming I can do alone
and it just I don't think I'm not
thinking about anything else just
thinking about it's competitive so it
definitely fills that
um but away from that I love music I
played guitar since I was young so
that's something for me you have to have
things in life I tell people like you
gotta have your your Finish Line moments
but you can have things that are just
for you doesn't matter if it where it
goes you know in the industry it doesn't
matter if it charts or it's an opening
it doesn't matter you pick it up you
love it it loves you back
and then that moment dissipates but it's
with you forever because you're pouring
yourself into something so I add that
with guitar
um I love my dogs I spend a lot of time
with my dog walking around a little bit
either it's a mirror or a or yeah yeah
the mirror in there I got a Rhodesian
Ridge back and uh this is Chopper he's a
Shepherd poodle
um so just things in my life that make I
love home I'm a homebody I love to
entertain the masses and then the second
my footsteps off stage Danica it's been
like this since 1990. the moment my foot
touches the ground
I'm off I don't need any other High I
don't chase it I may have in the middle
of my career because I wanted to find
the cool girls or like where's the party
for me or so but for the most part even
through that era it was like just get me
home so I can sit on the couch and go I
accomplished something I did something I
I overcame fear
I didn't let it make me feel like I used
to feel which is very low
and that's it and then rinse and repeat
I want to do it again
you're engaged right yeah what did you
what have you learned about
relationships I'm always so intrigued
what people's lessons are and how they
figure it out I made a decision some
years back that after being unlucky in
love and that only led to one good thing
which was uh bad relationships good
comedy
why does pain create art yeah yeah
no it was like the shittier the
relationship the funnier that weekend
was going to be that's why your comedy's
on the way out maybe you know like you
gotta find some
like the relationships well no no
because then there's going to be like
every comedian that gets married then of
course it's there you know perception uh
you know vantage point of of you know
married life so I I look forward to that
15 minutes of material coming together
I'll be interested to see what level of
Truth she's gonna let you talk about
yeah well when you meet somebody in
comedy you kind of know right away like
listen this is uh you know it all ends
up there in a version and so with Kelsey
she's awesome she has a in fact I have a
pretty like hardcore sense of humor and
even more so like you know in your in
your moments when you're alone and
there's a couple of friends how you can
really you know sometimes air it out
like she blows me away I've heard
everything and so we're on point because
her sense of humor is pretty Savage
sometimes in a very funny way
um I made a choice some years ago I was
like
if I meet somebody and I I really feel
like I care about them I really feel
like
um you know good person you know just
you've Fallen like I was like when I
fall in like with somebody
I'm gonna give them my whole heart for a
year
uh understanding that that is you know
everybody grows and changes in evolution
and Seasons but I was like I've never
given somebody this is years ago now
after the whole conversation with Paul
that I mentioned I was like give
somebody my whole heart everything for a
year and with Kelsey it was like a year
and then two years of being like okay
and even understanding like if this ends
now and it could end you know it things
weird [__] happens
I was like I can always say I loved
somebody but my whole heart for two
years and then it was three years
and then it was four years and I'm like
wow I'm that's I I subscribe to this
idea of just like being able to look at
myself in the mirror and say I know I
gave everything that I could to this and
it's okay where it goes because
I'll never if it ended I'll never go
well of course I [__] up year two I'm
the one who had some embroiled
and here we are six years later and
engaged to be married and it's the
greatest
it's the greatest I don't know it's it's
it's sappy and cliche and like a bad
rom-com but it's I love her it's the
greatest thing in my life oh is she in
the sort of like diving deep into
herself too yeah she's the same like we
we pretty much
um you know
uh the kinship
the simpatico I would even say was like
we understood pain we'd both been
treated pretty poorly by people but we
didn't hate people from it we didn't
want to just you know we felt neglected
but we love people and so I think just
we built it right off of that it was
like I get you you know it was simple it
was a real real simple thing you know I
used to hate myself and she was like I
used to feel the same way I did not I
was self-loathing she was like I was
like that and then giving the ultimate
trust in those conversations to like
you're building now off of like we know
that we know the worst of the worst of
each other
um and it just became something again
it's hard like people listening it's
like until you're the only way you're
ever going to be in it Danica I think is
to be able to look at yourself in the
mirror
and really know
I am I'm being very honest with myself
and if there's something that I need to
to um exercise
whether it's I'm I'm I'm unhappy in my
career I have moments I need forgiveness
on I'm seeking forgiveness if you don't
get right with yourself and kind of
sweep your side of the street
you're not going to meet that equal
you'll meet an equal
and bring in the the people who help
expose the pain and stuffing you so you
got to be right with yourself you got to
be like you got to be like your own hero
to be ready for real love
yeah how do you make that into comedy
well well my relationship with Kelsey
was made into comedy because we have an
age difference and it's like there's a
lot to you know have at that
um so there's places to still find
comedy even though the nucleus of it is
like yeah this is we're home bodies we
like to read we like to be home you know
we'll go out she'll be on tour with me
she's a Pilates instructor she's
certified she does nutrition like we do
our thing but we love being home and so
the comedy really comes from okay how
does the world then perceive your love
and trust me there's a lot of things to
laugh at that when you come out and see
the show and realize there's no way to
escape comedy it's it's it's good or bad
the The Vessel of life is always going
to bring something and populate the
stand-up set
um you know even if you feel like oh wow
okay there's no jokes to be had but
permission to speak freely I had done
every relationship joke you could
possibly do previous to that so I don't
feel like I missed anything what makes
good comedy I'm almost curious I'm
curious about that especially with all
the talk we have about like truth I'm
sure the truth is funny but sometimes
it's not maybe like what makes is there
even a formula for it what makes good
comedy is I think
I think it's a few different factors but
at at first
the Escape
the Escape mostly I think it's probably
80 percent of people trying to escape
some feeling in that comedy that laugh
it purges them of some weight heaviness
I think 20 is probably celebration in
celebration let's go out we'll have a
few drinks and let's go see a show and
laugh because I'm winning in life but I
think a lot of it is you know I look out
into the eyes of people sometimes
thousands and thousands of people
sometimes I'm just working on something
in La so I'm looking at 30 people
working on something new and it's the
same feeling of people are watching you
They're laughing is you know you talk to
them sometimes and you get to know them
and like you learn people's hardship
you'll say like what are you going what
are you dealing with and then all of a
sudden you're you know everybody in the
crowd is understanding like oh me too
like I'm feeling like that person but
then second to that there's a feeling I
think of watching a live performer
especially somebody alone on stage who's
taking you on a journey and there's
something kind of like
magical about that like damn that
person's up there and so the escapism is
also a bit of like just the Showmanship
of somebody being able to hold a crowd
in the palm of their hands that's
exciting so it's kind of two-tiered I
think the reasons that stand up and it's
so unique to everybody you know you
could have 10 comics on here and we
could all tell you 10 different reasons
that it works for us and some of its
Tempo and Cadence some of it's like you
know maybe culturally it's this is a
Chappelle shirt like Dave is somebody
who has always you know I started with
Dave in New York City and it's like just
always somebody who um
has steeped himself into a side of
conversation no matter what people's
perception is of it he's he's
fascinating because he's speaking a
truth Patrice O'Neal my my friend who
passed away some years ago was a comic
who said you know he can't [__] with the
truth so if you are the truth if it's
absurd truth if it's political humor
truth if it's physical truth it doesn't
matter what you're doing on stage if
it's real to you coming from that
Fantastical part of your brain that's
fascinated with what you're sharing I
think that's what the crowd is
responding to you're helping me escape
but I'm also watching you because you
have Love of the Game and this is
amazing to see you up there doing that
is comedy kind of unfuck-withable
because of the nature of it because
there's like a million and two ways of
being canceled these days and there's
just you can't [__] say anything
about anything without being offending
someone God I mean shoot this just came
to me but maybe comedy is how we get
back to being
having some like just like just pinch of
salt with everything man it's just not
so serious we're just a virus yeah it's
like we almost need something greater
than us to [__] with the whole world get
back some of the right yeah some
something that really bonds us again
right now comedy's in a little bit of a
it's kind of like it's back in a
speakeasy phase like real cool people
know they can go into a room somewhere
and just like we get it it's yeah we get
you know the Lenny Bruce era who you
know was arrested for speaking his mind
and being provocative and
um but I will say this I think that's
that some of some of what this um
culture has done for comedy in in one
area I think is good which is the real
mean-spirited
um grotesque ignorant comic it's not
they're not gonna have uh they're not
gonna Thrive
um and and not only they're not going to
thrive but that's not that that took up
a lot of stage time from a lot of people
that I think were really up there to
try to do a little bit of what we're
talking about which is like
Observe and Report on their truth I want
to hear your truth I don't want somebody
up there on stage talking about that guy
because he's black is doing this or that
I think that era of of reporting on
somebody else is very like it's aged out
and good because I'd rather have
somebody up there sharing their true
unadulterated you know maybe unbiased
perspective on here's what life is to be
that person that used to get made fun of
by another comic that had no you know
right really to be said I'd like to
stand on when it's your experience you
have a leg to stand on you have two of
them yeah yeah and if I want to see a
roast I want to see like you know kill
Tony or I want to see Jeff Ross or like
I get it I want to see everybody get
their balls busted and hazed and we we
all have stuff that we should be
laughing about ourselves and each other
leave it to the pros but that ignorant
era of Comedy over and is it too squeaky
clean and too um corporate run and yeah
big time but I do think that it'll um
it'll outlive all the changes in culture
I think one way or the other stand-up
comedy will be one of the last places as
it is today where you this is what's
beautiful about it what glamorous even
you can walk into a room tonight you can
sit down in a seat
there's no editor no standards of
practice nobody's saying you can or
can't or you can listen a person's ideas
directly to you
laugh or not laugh and regardless of
that you should love that because that's
a beautiful thing to be able to have a
room you can go into pay a ticket price
and go
this is the ride I might hate what I
hear I might not believe this might be
the best thing I've ever done with my
life is hearing this person's Wild
stories because it's true it's true and
you said standards and practices and um
I mean I just know from being around
television like when I hosted the ESPYs
a few years back and there was 15
writers in charge like I'm I am not a
funny human being okay like they're
there are 15 writers
um there were so many things that
wouldn't make it through standards and
practices to make the show right and so
you're totally right like anything on
television you see is is not I mean I
don't know does like Ricky Gervais like
go do the Oscars and you know like a
couple years ago when he just like
bombed everyone does he go up there and
totally just Riff on his own or or or
are there sometimes people that do that
because for the most part my
understanding is is that standards and
practices controls everything that's
right on television yeah because they're
looking up for the the investors the
advertisers yeah and so you you get it
you understand it you just wish that
like
we all wish that it was just different
from the top down and that more people
could go hey you know what this the this
is the American way we started this
thing off it was a big it's a bizarre
it's it's capitalist it's bring your
wares but here's the deal anybody in
this giant Mall of America you're we're
choosing to be here
and it's a little prickly because it's
going to be outspoken and sometimes the
sometimes the other guy is going to win
and you're gonna be like [__] now this
guy is making the rules but you roll
with it and you laugh it off and if you
can have those things to be able to
laugh off
then life is even more stressful and the
trials feel even more turbulent I think
with
um with stand up I tell people more than
ever if you love a comedian if you're
into stand-up comedy like truly support
them let that comic know build them up
write them a DM anything you could do
Comics today I promise you Danica more
than ever that they need to hear from
the people that believe in them because
they're going to start making decisions
based on what the industry tells them
and what the industry tells them is
change everything right yeah no that's
not gonna fly yeah so I I tell people
like you know I'm fortunate enough some
years back I started coming from a place
in my storytelling of just like I'm
gonna talk from my this is from how
either things have impacted me or things
that I've done outward and that's why I
think I can kind of get away with
anything because you're not gonna go why
who's he to talk about that no it's my
vantage point of life to and from and I
think that more comics are
um thriving because they're doing that
and the ones that still want to be you
know ignorant for the sake of shock
shock comedy is not in a good place
let's just say that what do you think
about
um Joe Rogan opening up the mothership
in Austin felt like some and I I've not
been there yet although I do kind of
plan on going when I go for the Austin
F1 race later this year
um but is it is that is that a place
where people can kind of say whatever
they want and uncensored and and do you
think that's going to be something that
catches on with people because you say
like you know being able to do the
underground stuff like right yo there's
underground I'm sure but then there's
also just people that say I own the
place say whatever you want right you
know that's still gonna exist no matter
what right there's always going to be
some maybe a Community member you know
somebody the mayor there's always going
to be probably somebody who's going to
you know be have pushback when there's
that absolute freedom especially freedom
of speech in any situation but in terms
of Joe in that place I mean first of all
it looks beautiful
um I'm I'm proud of them for doing that
and I think that I hope that Comics are
going to feel like well that is a place
that I can go and I can mess up I can
screw up you know that's the whole thing
about
early comedy see you don't get you don't
get pedigree
pedigree comes from you step in it you
step you s you say stupid things really
because that's where pedigree comes from
wow yeah yeah you learn because you [__]
up and then you go and then stand up if
you're not allowed to have those
formative years then you're you're not
going to become you know look at Shane
Gillis like what a great example of like
gets fired from Saturday Night Live
thankfully friend of Rogan friend of
that that community
you know he's thriving he's finding his
way forward when he was canceled because
of something that if if nobody had
canceled him he might on his own gone
through the in self-interpretation and
understood and made made funny out of
here's where my ignorance was funny or
something I haven't even thought of
before he was almost like squelched
before he had a chance to even shine so
for somebody like him and for a lot of
comics that I think Rogan is going to
provide that portal I think it's going
to feel like a safe haven for a lot of
people I think that I would even gamble
on I think he's going to turn Austin
into the comedy hot spot I think it
might I think that might be the next big
comedy City if he's going to do that the
way I think we all know Joe does
something which is
he puts his whole self into whatever it
is that he's doing so I I want it to win
and win big
do comedians get along
is it a friendly
environment um it's like your graduating
class gets along and then what what used
to happen I think it's really kind of
not this way anymore but what used to
happen is like if the class in front of
you if you jumped over somebody and you
became popular then it was almost like
pecking order and you would find that
that graduating class in front of you
was not very friendly
um
when I made it it was like
there was Mike Bill Burr Gary Goldman
Patrice O'Neal a lot of guys out of
Boston very supportive of each other the
graduating class in front of us didn't
wasn't really happy to see us there and
then the graduating class behind us of
course was like wanted to ingratiate
themselves and learn more how do I how
can I do that find Value in it I found
as my career went further that like the
comics that were really established you
know the Eddie Murphy's and yeah Bob
Saget and Robin Williams like they
really embraced me and especially at
times when I was getting kicked in the
teeth and having my own spanking machine
moments in the industry then those
classes much further down the the line
that were kind of set they were really
um my safe havens and a lot of love came
from those guys well thank God for
comedy I mean honestly I I I I love
going to comedy shows are you coming to
Phoenix anytime actually just today I
got uh an offer to do again you're here
today no no just I just signed a phoenix
gig today
um cool I remember the name of the
theater but I'm gonna be down there in
October I'm gonna come see that oh cool
we'll stay in touch so I can make sure
that you're uh you can come through with
your with your squad amazing
um and you're on tour generally right
just came off of the first phase the
rest of the Summers planning for the
wedding in September and then back on
the road October November uh man Texas
Florida
Boston New York Arizona and a couple
more spots danecook.com has all that
good stuff that's really cool I love
that and um and then uh you have a show
that's
um available right
yeah so the the last special I did above
it all it's it's pretty much anywhere if
you search it online you can get it on
any device or it's on my website and
then working on the documentary that
we're going to film probably through
July and August and then my director
will go off and try to figure out uh how
to make a you know how to how to
whatever whatever he has to do to you
know put the bookends on it what's it
for what's the dock for anyway so some
years I'm not allowed to talk too much
about it because I'm under contract with
the documentary but they approached me
the the Under the Umbrella of I had to
put I had to put a family member in
prison years ago for theft
and so the documentary explores
My Philosophy leading up to how I made
it out of this you know childhood that I
shared with you
only to have at the highest high water
mark moment in my life this my parents
had passed and then I was putting my
brother in prison and so the documentary
really goes into in a way that people
some people kind of know the story a
little from podcasts but
it's really dark and twisted and it goes
into some places that I I think people
are going to be blown away at what I'm
about to share
but it's also very funny it's also
something I can look at in my life and
there's a lot of humor and I think it's
the I think if we do our job right
it's the ultimate comedy and tragedy in
one story it's always the best when you
take them on a roller coaster ride
that's for sure have you ever heard of
Gabor mate yeah okay have you ever
talked to Gabor no
Gabor is great yeah I just think that
you you'd love his stuff because it's
it's like he is like the best at
childhood trauma and traumas like
he is like so good at that that stuff if
you've I was gonna say if you ever if
you end up doing like a group you know
I don't know if anybody ever does a
group uh you know interviews but it'd be
kind of cool to mix and match and put a
few people together keep me in mind
because I even if I'm just a fly in the
wall I I would love to ask some
questions and and even listen in on
something like that and I was really
really excited to be a part of this
today so thank you for you know
including me been a fan review for a
long time remember you for a long time
well the feeling is so very mutual thank
you well we're getting up there you know
we're we're not old let's not call it
old we're getting worse
no way yeah I don't I don't even know
what age is I've never really I don't
feel
you know sometimes my knees feel a
little different but I still I don't
know they make stem cells for that just
go get some more injections go to Costa
Rica like I did
easier
I'm gonna live till 120 so you know
I'll meet you there sounds good
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button